Hallihallo.
Hallo Stefan. Wir treffen uns wieder in Frankfurt, damit wir es analog aufzeichnen können und damit wir in die Oper gehen können.
In welche gehen wir denn?
Wir gehen in Elektra.
Ist das eine gute Oper?
Das ist eine herausragend gute Oper. Eine meiner Lieblingsopern, um genauer zu sein. Es ist eine Oper von Richard Strauss, die sehr massiv ist, die die Grenzen überschreitet, die vom Wahnsinn handelt, von Menschen, die keinen Schlaf mehr finden, es ist eine wirklich verrückte Oper im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und ich liebe sie sehr und bin gespannt, was sie daraus machen.
Eben, du bist gespannt, was sie daraus machen. Kann man viel verkehrt machen?
Nicht allzu viel. Die Musik ist unzerstörbar.
Also zur Not Augen zu und durch?
Ja, es ist so gut und dicht konstruiert. Man kann eigentlich wenig verkehrt machen. Klar, man kann sich jetzt irgendein Konzept ausdenken, dass man einfach drüber stülpt und dann funktioniert das Ganze nicht. Aber wann immer ich Elektra gesehen habe, war es gut bis sehr gut. Und ich hoffe auch, dass das diesmal so sein wird.
Ja, ich habe vom Flohfunk gehört aus den Kulturredaktionen Deutschlands. Gibt es noch Karten? Hast du noch Karten für Elektra? Ist nämlich alles ausverkauft?
Tatsächlich.
Wir sehen es heute und es gibt großen Bedarf. Aber die Spielzeiten enden ja auch irgendwann. Und dann hat man so einen Überblick, dass man es wahrscheinlich für Monate nicht mehr sehen wird. Wir können uns also glücklich schätzen heute. Sehr gut. Ich bin natürlich gespannt. Du hast mich jetzt ein bisschen gehypt und sie geht ja auch weniger als zwei Stunden.
Ja, ein Akte.
Es ist ja alles in freudiger Erwartung dann soweit.
Ja, beziehungsweise wir werden da sehr, sehr intensive zwei Stunden erleben. Also wir sind gespannt darauf. Ich habe ja mir ein günstiges Hotel gebucht. Also ich habe mir gedacht, ich nehme das Standard Hotel. Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Namen nennen darf, ohne dass das jetzt als Werbung erscheint. Also ich gehe in ein Motel One und bin im letzten Jahr in vielen Motel Ones gewesen und in vielen, vielen anderen Hotels. Und ich habe mich auch nochmal gefragt, wie würde eigentlich der Sozialismus aussehen und wie die Hotels im Sozialismus. Und was mir aufhält…
Oh, wie kam es auf die Frage, sagen wir es nochmal zu Genese der Frage.
Wenn man sich ein besseres Hotel gönnt, bis zu 5 Sternen, dann hat das zwar hin und wieder den Effekt, dass es irgendwelche Spa-Bereiche gibt, die ich nicht aufsuche oder Riesen-Frühstücks-Buffets, die ich nicht brauche. Aber sonst tut sich gerade, was den Service beim Ein- und Auschecken anbelangt, nicht viel, im Gegenteil, es wird eher komplizierter. Also eher steht man in einem teureren Hotel länger an der Rezeption als in einem günstigen. Und Motel One ist ja so, dass man dort sehr schnell, ich will jetzt nicht für alle Motel Ones sprechen, aber meine Erfahrung ist, man wird sehr schnell drangenommen, kommt sehr schnell dann auf sein Zimmer, das Zimmer ist standardisiert. Ich muss mich nicht nochmal erstmal unten in der Rezeption dreimal versichern, wie man eigentlich Licht an- und ausmacht und wie man das Wasser heiß bekommt in der Dusche. Da gibt es ja mittlerweile Apparaturen, ich verzweifle da mitunter. Und dann beim Auschecken werfe ich einfach dieses Kärtchen hinein und bin weg. Ich muss nicht nochmal 2, 80 Euro zahlen, weil ich irgendwie ein Wasser auf dem Zimmer getrunken habe. Es gibt einfach kein Wasser noch auf dem Zimmer, das ich da trinken kann. Man kann sich unten etwas holen. Und ich würde auch sagen, ich finde es ein bisschen albern, wenn man zum Teil in Hotels untergebracht ist. Ich werde ja manchmal auch von sehr netten Veranstaltern sehr gut untergebracht. Und dann sieht man so, die Zimmer kosten hier eigentlich 240 Euro. Und dann ist aber da irgendwie eine Minibar, in der man für 3, 20 Euro eine Cola kaufen kann. Wo ich denke, kann man es nicht dann bei den 240 Euro belassen? Oder dann schlag noch 10 Euro drauf und inkludiert das einfach da drin. Aber ihr könnt doch nicht den Gast noch mal unten nerven, mit haben sie dann da noch eine Cola und vielleicht noch einen Snickers konsumiert? Ja, ich finde es furchtbar.
Ich kann das spiegeln. Ich war auf Einladung die letzten Monate für eine Nacht in einem der Top 3 Hotels Deutschlands. Ich nenne aber jetzt keine Namen. Ich habe gar keine Lust auf irgendeine juristische Auseinandersetzung. Man weiß ja nicht, was da droht. Und ich war auch ein bisschen ernüchtert, muss ich sagen. Auch wenn es eher so persönliche Sachen sind, die mich wirklich stören. Wenn ich über den Pariser Platz schlender, mit einem Koffer in der Hand, für eine Nacht glaube ich nicht, dass ich aussehe, als bräuchte ich Hilfe, um drei Stufen zu bewältigen. Es stehen aber drei Leute da, die mich fragen, ob ich Hilfe brauche, wo ich schon mal denke, ne, ich will gar nicht begrüßt werden als lieber 100-jähriger Standardgast. Brauchen sie Hilfe bei diesen drei Stufen? Nein, brauche ich nicht. So, sehr gute Rezeptionserfahrung, da will ich nichts sagen. Und dann auf dem Zimmer. Ich habe ja die Angewohnheit, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, sehr diszipliniert zu sein. Ich kaufe nämlich nichts, was meinem Körper schädigt. Allerdings lebe ich ja mit Kindern zusammen, die immer Nachtisch wollen. Nachtisch heißt die Süßigkeit. Also gibt es zu Hause sehr viele Süßigkeiten. So diszipliniert ich beim Einkaufen bin, so undiszipliniert bin ich zu Hause.
Das heißt, du isst den Kindern alles weg?
So ungefähr. Was mich auch nervt und stört. Dann komme ich in mein Hotelzimmer. Alle Lichter an. Ich frage mich, warum. Und beleuchtet sind vor allem zwei große Schrankregale, keine Ahnung, so Glas, Holz und so weiter, in denen nur Süßigkeiten stehen. Tafel und Schokolade, die ich noch nie gesehen habe, tüten Popcorn und ich denke mir so, nein, das brauche ich gar nicht auf meinem Zimmer. Soll ich jetzt anrufen und sagen, holen sie es bitte ab? Ich möchte auf gar keinen Fall jetzt zehn Stunden neben einer 30 Gramm Tafel Schokolade sitzen, die die ganze Zeit angeleuchtet wird, wo dann auf so einem Zettel steht 7. Und ich mir denke, okay, das scheint der Preis zu sein. Man ist zu cool, ein Eurozeichen dahinter zu schreiben, es ist einfach 7.
Einfach 7.
Und ich frage mich dann, wie kommt es zu diesem Preis? Hat man das einfach irgendwo an Mass eingekauft, auf die Hotelkettenhäuser verteilt und sich dann überlegt, machen wir mal 7.
Klingt irgendwie schön.
Drei wäre zu billig. Wir haben ja gehobene Gäste.
Ja, genau, drei ist zu billig. Das ist aber gar nicht eine Tafel Schokolade für 7.
Kostet irgendwie 7 Euro, keine Ahnung. Und dann liege ich im Bett und kriege das Nachtlicht nicht aus. Also ich habe neben meinem Bett eine Schublade, in der sind 10 Lichtschalter. Ich kann das Bad an- und ausmachen und so weiter. Aber im Bad und im Bett ist so passiv beleuchtet unter dem Möbel Licht.
Ja, hasse ich, wie die passt.
Und ich habe es nicht ausgekriegt. Ich bin dann ins Bad, weil es war ja eine Glastür zum Bad, es scheint also durch, hab dann Handtücher vor das Waschbecken auf die Stange gehangen, um das möglichst abzudunkeln. Bis ich dann auf dem Weg zurück ins Bett, ein Uhr nachts gesehen habe, ah, da ist der Lichtschalter für Nachtlicht. Konnte ich es dann noch ausmachen, aber es hat mich 20 Minuten gekostet. Da habe ich auch gedacht, dafür will ich jetzt nicht in der Rezeption anrufen. Das war wieder besonders toll. Ich lege mein Handy auf dieses kleine Radio, was da steht, weil Charging ohne Kabel und so. Dann greife ich nachts nach dem Handy und komme aber auf einem der Knöpfe, oben auf derselben Oberfläche, wo man sein Handy hinlegt. Plötzlich höre ich nur, tuuut, tuuut, nicht so, habe ich jetzt jemanden angerufen. Also suchen, wo ist der Lichtschalter, Schubladeauflicht an. Ah ja, ich habe tatsächlich angerufen. Ich habe jemanden angerufen, aus Versehen, zwei Uhr nachts, wo ich nur zum Handy greifen wollte. Da habe ich auch gedacht, ich reiße jetzt mal ab und verstehe nicht, wieso es solche Hotelzimmer gibt, die ab 900 Euro kosten. Was? Für Wochenende, Aufenthalte pro Nacht. Es ist grotesk. Da habe ich auch gedacht, irgendwo ist eine Grenze. Das meine ich jetzt nicht so, irgendwo ist eine Grenze, sondern irgendwo ist eine Grenze. Hotelzimmer ab 150 Euro verbessern sich nicht mehr. Meiner Erfahrung nach, es kommt dann auf andere Sachen an, für die das Hotel erst mal so nichts kann, Lage usw. Aber es macht irgendwie keinen Sinn. Es macht Sinn für, sagen wir mal, Menschen ab 80 Jahre, die wirklich viel Hilfe brauchen.
Nein, ich glaube ja nicht, dass das die Klientel unbedingt ist. Sondern wir haben da ein sehr internationales Publikum in diesen großen, sehr teuren Hotels. Ich sehe das ja auch in Düsseldorf, wenn man da an manchen Hotels vorbeigeht, die sehr auch sehr namenhaft sind. Oder ich habe das jetzt auch in Hamburg erlebt, da ich mit dem Taxi durchfuhr an einem anderen sehr bekannten Hotel vorbei. Da steigen nicht die 80-Jährigen ab, sondern da steigen auch die 30-Jährigen ab. Und die finden das offenbar toll. Sie wollen sich aber dann die ganze Zeit mit diesem Zimmer beschäftigen. Ich glaube, wir sind ja Menschen, die wollen, dass es funktioniert. Und wir wollen reibungslos reisen können, ohne Friktionen die Termine wahrnehmen, die man hat. Und man möchte nicht sagen, ich habe leider schlecht geschlafen, denn ich musste 47 Lichter ausschalten. Genauso ist es für mich ein großes Problem, dass es alles so dunkel ist in Hotels. In manchen Badezimmern habe ich mir schon das Nachttischlämpchen hineingetragen, um ein bisschen mehr Licht zu haben. Oder was mich auch wahnsinnig stört, dass es in den meisten Hotels immer nur indirektes Licht gibt. Ich hätte gerne ein Deckenlicht, denn ich bin ein Mensch, der noch Bücher liest. Ich würde gerne es hell haben. Und ich muss nicht immer eine Nachtbar-Stimmung haben, wenn ich tagsüber in einem Hotel sitze. Was mich richtig aggressiv macht, ist übrigens ein Tütchen Gummibärchen, dieses so ein kleines Tütchen auf dem Kissen.
So was, naja.
Könnte ich ausflippen. Aber was ich noch sagen wollte zu meiner Sozialismus-Idee, also auch im Sozialismus muss es natürlich Hotels geben, aber wie du das jetzt eben gerade so schön sagtest, wo verbessert sich denn da eigentlich noch irgendein Standard? Nein, ich glaube, man muss einen gewissen Standard haben und das Komfortable liegt vor allem daran, dass es frictionsfrei ist. Und deswegen schätze ich, und ich will das jetzt hier keine Werbung machen für eine Hotelkette, aber es gibt ja auch andere Hotelketten dieser Art, wo man sehr unkompliziert rein kann und wo dafür gesorgt ist, dass alles gut funktioniert. Bei manchen ist es dann vielleicht ein bisschen zu spartanisch. Ich brauche auch ein entsprechend großes Bett und ich will auch absolute Ruhe haben. Ich hasse es auch, wenn man nicht richtig dunkel machen kann. Aber so generell ist diese Idee, dass man einfach eine Standardisierung hineinbringt, die mir das Leben, wenn ich auf Reisen bin, nicht noch erschwert. Das ist etwas, was eigentlich sehr, sehr positiv ist. Und ich finde das schon toll, wenn solche Abläufe einfach funktionieren. Wenn man nicht alles so verkomplizieren muss. Ich begreife auch nicht, warum ich online ein Hotel buche und dann doch wieder alles händisch ausfüllen muss, wenn ich an der Rezeption ankomme. Wozu? Solche Dinge sind aber immer wieder vorzufinden. Das ist jetzt ja Klagen auf hohem Niveau gewiss. Aber ich glaube, die Hotels müssen besser werden. Und ich bin gerne bereit, da mal mit Rat und Tat zur Seite zu stehen und zu sagen, wo hängt man ein Deckenlicht auf? Und weshalb ist es eigentlich sinnvoll, wenn es einen kleinen Abtrenner gibt zwischen Dusche und Badezimmer, sodass, wenn man duschen war, nicht das ganze Bad unter Wasser gesetzt hat?
Ja, und wir sagen noch mal dazu, weil du sagst, Klagen auf hohem Niveau ist es nicht. Es ist Klagen in einem besonderen Milieu.
Genau.
Wir reisen ja nicht aus touristischen Gründen, sondern hier geht es ja darum, wir werden eingeladen, wir sollen auf einer Bühne ein bisschen was performen und so weiter. Da braucht man zum einen schon eine erste Klassefahrt, weil ich bin jetzt nächste Woche in Hamburg. Es macht gar keinen Sinn, zweite Klasse nach Hamburg zu fahren und dann in so ein shitty Hotel zu gehen. Weil dann hat man in den acht Stunden, bevor man auf der Bühne steht, wirklich ein scheiß Leben gehabt. Also im Sinne von, ja man kann mal mit der zweiten Klasse irgendwo hinfahren und dann dort einfach einen guten Tag mit seinen Kiddies oder so haben. Aber wenn man abends nochmal vor hunderten Leuten irgendwie, dann ist es gut, diesen Tag entsprechend zu strukturieren. Und daher würde ich schon sagen, nee, da reicht dann kein 80 Hotelzimmer, sondern 150 Hotelzimmer. Aber es macht keinen Sinn, in 300 Euro Hotelzimmer zu nehmen. Also da ist irgendwo, würde ich auch sagen, gibt es noch Beratungsbedarf und Abguck-Bedarf.
Abguck-Bedarf vor allem, ja.
Man kann sich noch mal die guten Sachen zum Problem nehmen.
Also wie schnell was gehen kann, also gerade wie schnell auschecken gehen kann. Es kann nicht sein, dass man noch mal da steht und schon eine Viertelstunde mit einrechnen muss, weil man noch weiß, naja, das könnte sich alles noch sehr verzögern, auch weil man noch irgendeine Kaution zurück haben muss. Das finde ich ja auch so albern. Die haben alle Daten von einem. Man hat das Zimmer bezahlt und dann wollen die 50 Euro Kaution, sollte man die Minibar plündern. Dann denke ich mir, sollte dies der Fall sein und sollte der Gast das nicht unten angeben? Man findet den ja wieder. Man muss ja nicht diese 50 Euro Kaution haben, dass man denkt, sonst bin ich verloren. Aber ja, das war jetzt unser kleiner Ausflug zum Hotel. Wir springen jetzt zu einer anderen Reise, die der Wirtschaftsminister gemacht hat, nämlich Habeck hat Zelensky besucht, war in der Ukraine. Und da kam es zu einem sehr eigenartigen Dialog. Vor Fernsehkameras betone ich hier, denn das ist das Entscheidende, was die intern da reden. Das ist ja nochmal was ganz anderes, aber dass dies hier vor Fernsehkameras geschieht, finde ich ziemlich ungeheuerlich. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich, dass wir 2021 kennengelernt sind. Aber ich fühle mich schade, dass es zu spät ist. Wie kann das sein? Wir wissen, dass das Spiel auch in einer Regierung ist, dass man sich gegenseitig einen mitgibt. Kürzlich, du hattest davon erzählt, gib dann Scholz Habeck noch mal einen mit. Oder Habeck gibt Lindner einen mit. Das ist ja das interne Spiel in der Bundesrepublik und in jedem anderen Land auch. Aber dass man jetzt in ein anderes Land fährt und dort nicht geschlossen als Regierung auftritt, sondern sagt, naja, also man lässt es ja so ein bisschen offen. Wir haben uns da 2021 schon mal gesprochen und da war das ja noch so und so. Wo man auch sagen muss, da war das ja auch für Zelensky erstmal sehr fern noch gewesen, wie man immer wieder dann auch in Interviews hörte. Und dann sagt man, naja, er sei zutiefst beschämt darüber, dass man zu spät Waffen geliefert hat.
Na, dass man auf ihn nicht gehört hat.
Ja, und dass man auf ihn nicht gehört hat, das finde ich schon eine sehr eigenartige Sache. Also das Kanzleramt hat das natürlich dann gleich richtig gestellt und sagt, dass sie das überhaupt nicht so sehen, dass sie es so spät geliefert haben. Aber ich finde, das ist schon eine sehr, sehr merkwürdige Vorgehensweise von Habeck, da jetzt noch mal öffentlich eigentlich zu sagen, der Scholz stand halt auf der Bremse.
Und Annalena Baerbock noch damals auch, oder? Wenn ich mich nicht recht erinnere.
Naja, das wissen wir ja bei Huisgen, dass noch drei Tage vorher eigentlich Annalena Baerbock gesagt hat, ne, wir sehen und dann nicht uns in der Verantwortung. Und dann begann der Krieg und dann hat man da plötzlich die Position geändert. Und wir wissen doch jetzt durch all diese Debatten und Panzerlieferungen und so, inwieweit diese ganzen Lieferungen abgestimmt sind mit den NATO-Partnern, vor allem mit Washington. Und das hier noch mal so getan wird, als sei jetzt das Problem gewesen, dass Deutschland nicht schnell genug wollte. Diese mehr hat sich doch jetzt wirklich in Luft aufgelöst. Die hört man ja auch immer seltener, selbst von den Einschlägen der Journalisten.
Ich weiß noch, kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie Habeck zurückkam damals, irgendwie Oktober 21 oder so, und meinte, wir sollten jetzt mal schwere Waffen liefern. Nee, 21, vor dem Krieg. Habeck war vor dem Krieg in der Ukraine und hat damals, kam zurück und forderte plötzlich so schwere Waffen. Und alle so, hä, wieso? Und so, naja, weil die Russen ziehen doch da auf. Naja, die blöffen ja nur und so, und das haben wir ja auch bei Häusken gelernt, wie man so bis die Tage vorher und wir alle nicht dachten, dass es wirklich passiert. Vielleicht ist eben wirklich daran gelegen, nochmal Journalisten dran zu erinnern, was in den Geschichtsbüchern stehen sollte in der Chronologie dieses Krieges, dass nämlich Habeck, bevor der Krieg begann, schon schwere Waffen forderte und danach nur 5000 Helme versprochen wurden. Diesen Eindruck hat man ja häufiger auch bei Scholz. Es ist ja so ein ganz subtiles, er wird ja immer mal wieder drauf angesprochen. Ja und sie galt immer als Zögerer, jetzt zögern aber die anderen. Und dann macht er aber nur so einen Verweis auf ja, ja, ja und so. Also er lässt das bei so einem Halbsatz, wo ich mir auch denke, ah ja, das ist dann wirklich diese Merkel-Taktik. Nur kurz darauf hinzuweisen, ja, ja, aber wenn ich es aufarbeite, ist Quatsch, ihr müsst das jetzt aufarbeiten. Und ich glaube, das ist alles jetzt schon Wahlkampf, obwohl es ja eigentlich noch anderthalb, zwei Jahre sind. Aber das ist alles schon Wahlkampf, was wir da sehen. Wir sehen nur noch Positionierungen untereinander. Bis hin zu, dass die FDP dann jetzt auf Twitter sehr aktiv, also Konstantin Kuhle, der irgendwie eher abschneidende Tendenzen gegen Christian Lindner findet. Weil angeblich irgendwer, also irgendwer behauptet, dass Christian Lindner angeblich gegen die Kindergrundsicherung wäre. Das kann der Kuhle gar nicht, das kriegt er gar nicht in sein.
Konstantin Kuhle will, muss noch Karriere machen. Er will ja auch jeden Abend bei Micky Beisenherz in der Talkshow sitzen. Da muss man natürlich noch mal jetzt...
Genau, also Konstantin Kuhle macht sich gerade zum Sprachrohr. Da muss man natürlich zeigen, dass man kämpfen kann. Und Buschmann hat getwittert, wir sollten in der Regierung nicht mehr alle übereinander herfallen und so weiter, denn wir brauchen ja jetzt, Zitat, super additive Ergebnisse, super additiv. Also mittlerweile erfindet man sich eigentlich, also irgendwelche Worte oder nimmt sie sich so aus völlig fremden Genre.
Additiv ist ja aneinanderreihend.
Das Gute der Grünen, das Gute der Liberalen und dann alles auf so einen Berg und das ist dann der Berg des Guten irgendwie. Und die SPD legt da noch was drauf. Also man versucht jetzt mit Sprachbildern, sie gönnen sich untereinander nichts mehr. Ich habe es ja auch in dem einen Fernsehpodcast jetzt noch mal.
Aber ich hatte ja auch so eine komische Aussage von, wir haben die Handlungsfähigkeit wiederhergestellt oder so. In etwa hat er sich zu diesen unglaublichen Erfolgen geäußert in dieser extremen Koalitionskrise, die wir alle am eigenen Leibe ganz schlimm erlebt haben den letzten Wochen.
Es ist alles ganz schräg und ich habe in dem einen Fernsehpodcast jetzt auch noch mal den allen Journalisten einfach empfohlen, nicht mehr darüber zu rätseln, ob sich die Koalitionspartner noch verstehen, sondern einfach zu sehen, nein, sie verstehen sich nicht, sie sind alle in Opposition zueinander, aber sie regieren trotzdem. Sie müssen sich ja nicht verstehen. Es ist ja ein arbeitsteiliger Funktionszusammenhang. Sie haben halt einen klaren Auftrag bekommen und haben den dann angenommen, das gemeinsam zu machen. Aber man kann jetzt einfach abhaken, irgendwer hat irgend wem reingekrätscht, wie finden sie das denn oder so? Nein, man kann jetzt einfach bei der Sache bleiben und einfach mitlaufen lassen, dass sie sich halt nicht verstehen. Das ist halt ein normales Konkurrenzverhältnis. Ich frag mich das auch mal in den Medienhäusern, läuft das doch genauso? Kämpft auch Wirtschaftsredaktion gegen Politikredaktion um irgendwelche Plätze und Blattlinien und so weiter und jeder will seinen Punkt irgendwie machen. Warum vermuten die oder wollen die immer, dass das in der Regierung anders läuft? Nein, alle kämpfen gegen alle und sollen sie mal bei der Sache bleiben jetzt.
Ja, ein noch merkwürdigerer Auftritt ist sicherlich der von Campino. Und zwar gab es eine Dokumentation, die ich mir nicht angesehen habe. Ich habe nur den Trailer zufällig bei YouTube entdeckt. Es gab vor einigen Wochen eine Dokumentation zum Thema, sollen wir die Wehrpflicht oder die Dienstpflicht einführen, wieder einführen. Dort kamen mehrere Prominente zu Wort, unter anderem auch Campino. Unser großes Idol für alle, die immer subversiv waren und dann doch sich nachher den Frag angezogen haben, um mit Giffey zum Empfang zu gehen. Na ja, also ich muss natürlich, ich habe ja in Harald Schmidt Interviews gelernt, dass man immer, um justiziabel auf dem richtigen Weg zu sein, muss man immer so loben. Einfach übertrieben loben. Also unser Punk Rockstar, unser Lieblingspunker, der beste Punker der Welt. Campino äußert sich jetzt hier in diesem sehr kurzen Clip zur Dienstpflicht-Wehrpflicht.
Alleine die Tatsache, dass man für ein Jahr seines Lebens nicht selber entscheidet, wo es jetzt lang zu gehen hat, sondern dass jemand anders sagt, Freundchen, du tanzst hier nächsten Montag an und so. Das kann nicht schaden.
Wir haben es hier mit einem Mann zu tun, der mit seiner grandiosen Musik, die wir alle abgöttisch lieben, extrem reich geworden ist und der natürlich nie gesagt bekommt, Montags, Freundchen, tanz du an. Wir haben es zugleich aber mit fast nur Menschen in Deutschland zu tun, die zehn bis zwölf, dreizehn Jahre auf einer Schule waren und montags antanzen mussten, weil die Schule das so vorsieht, die danach vielleicht eine Ausbildung machen, wo sie montags antanzen müssen oder sie studieren, da können sie vielleicht auch mal montags ausschlafen, um danach 40 bis 45 Jahre als Angestellte zu arbeiten, wo ein Chef ihnen sagt, und montags, Freundchen, tanzt du an. Und jetzt sagt Campino, das würde eigentlich auch mal den Leuten gut tun, wenn sie mal so ein Jahr gesagt bekämen, ja, montags musst du antanzen.
Ja, wir müssen es als das benennen, was es ist, und zwar überall, wo wir es sehen. Zum einen, das ist pure Menschenverachtung und beruht eben auf einem völlig verqueren Menschenbild, das wirklich komplett quer zur Realität liegt. Und damit haben wir auch einen Brückenschlag zum Salon.
Denn du hast ein Buch gelesen von...
Ach so, okay, dann mach deinen ersten Brückenschlag. Ich bin noch mal bei Campino und ich nenne mal grob Altersgenossen. Ijoma Mangold ist Jahrgang 71, nach meiner rein mathematisch gefassten Definition von Boomer fällt er noch in die Boomer-Generation, so wie Campino auch. Und wir lesen im Salon ein Buch von einem Mann, das nach Lektüre mir das Fürchten gelehrt hat, und zwar vor der Person, die uns allen und mir am gefährlichsten werden kann, wie ich selbst, beispielsweise in 10 Jahren, es ist wieder einmal die Bestätigung, man muss wirklich aufpassen, wie man altert. Es könnte sein, dass man somit, oh man, morgen bin ich 50, plötzlich in so eine Sinnkrise fällt und die ganze Welt einfach mitreisen möchte, nur nach hanebüchenen Stuss schreibt, sein Menschenbild wie Campinos komplett auf links krempelt, oder rechts in dem Falle, und einfach verirrt, aber mit extremer publizistischer Lautstärke durch die Welt stolpert, als käme es nicht drauf an, dass wir morgen auch noch ein gutes Leben haben wollen. Also es ist wirklich brutal gefährlich.
Stefan, du nimmst einen meiner Schlussproannten für den Salon schon vorweg, aber ich will das hier schon machen. Sollte es mal so arg mit mir werden, wir machen ja hier noch einige Jahre zusammen. Das kann ja passieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie es passiert, aber es kann offenbar passieren.
Wir können uns einfach nicht sicher sein.
Du musst dich dann einfangen. Du musst dann sagen, Wolfgang, so geht es nicht weiter. Also davon möchte ich wirklich beschützt werden.
Sagt uns Bescheid, wenn wir den Podcast einstellen sollen. Wenn ich hier Sachen höre, die nicht mehr vertretbar sind. Man verliert offenbar als Mann ab gewissem Alter jegliche Maßstäbe. Es ist wirklich brutal. Deswegen.
Wir können festhalten, so ein Buch haben wir noch nie gelesen im Salon. Und deswegen lohnt es sich. Wir gestapeln sich wirklich die Notizen. Du hast acht Seiten, ich habe fünf Seiten. Alles vollgeschrieben. Das Buch gibt sehr viel her, aber vielleicht nicht so, wie der Autor sich das wünscht. Aber wir werden sehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall das, worüber wir sprechen wollen. Du hast aber auch noch einen Lichtblick, glaube ich, mitgebracht. Eine junge Stimme, die noch fertig ist.
Also wir sehen es ja auf Twitter. Es gibt einzelne Aktionen. Oder sagen wir mal so, sehr viele Menschen wollen gerade die Welt retten. Sie glauben, lasst den Leo 2 frei und die Welt wird besser und so. Also sehr viel Aktivismus auf dieser. Dann haben wir natürlich sehr viel Klimaaktivismus. Also Menschen kleben sich fest, werfen mit Gemüse und feiern sich dafür. Alles berechtigt, alles gut. Haben wir auch diskutiert. Und dann gibt es so eine kleine Bappel an sehr engagierten jungen Frauen. Zum Beispiel Helena Steinhaus, sanktionsfrei. Also die so einen Verein hat, wo man hinspenden kann. Die kümmert sich dann um die härtesten Härtefälle, die der Staat einfach gar nicht mehr durchlässt. Und dann werden einfach mal ein paar Hartz-IV-Leistungen aus privater Tasche gezahlt, wo der Staat ausfällt. Ungleichheit Info, ein Dessertationsprojekt von Martina Linatas. Und wir kennen sie wahrscheinlich, Kanzin Köktürk. Sie stand auf der Bühne bei den Grünen, als der Koalitionsvertrag frei reif zur Unterschrift dalag. Und meinte, das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein. Sie arbeitet als Sozialarbeiterin und hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben. Unsozialstaat Deutschland, warum wir radikal humanistisch werden müssen. Und ich möchte als Kontrapunkt zu Mangold. Ich werde viel aus dem Buch gleich lesen, statt das klassisch zu besprechen. Hier schon mal eine eigentlich irgendwie kitschige Stelle vorlesen, die aber doch im Kontext eines Buches, deswegen auch nochmal Lob eines, also der Form Buch, vielleicht reicht nicht immer ein Tweet aus. Vielleicht muss man doch mal ein Buch schreiben. Aber als Kontrapunkt zu Mangold, und da könnt ihr jetzt schon mal erahnen, wie schlimm Mangold ist, schreibt Köktürk. Liebe verbindet uns, und damit meine ich nicht nur die Liebe zwischen Paaren oder innerhalb Beziehungen. Ich meine die Liebe, jemandem etwas Gutes zu tun, zu helfen, sich solidarisch zu verhalten, weil wir eben dieselben Bedürfnisse teilen. Liebe kann Brücken schlagen, sich zu kümmern, kann uns wieder zusammenführen und uns unsere Einsamkeit und Dunkelheit im Herzen nehmen. Grücksichtnahme auf die Menschen, mit denen man diese Erde teilt, ein Blick auf ihre Not und eben der Wille da zu sein, hinzusehen und zu helfen, sich endlich zu bemühen und Verständnis zu zeigen, dass man sich einige Verläufe im Leben nicht ausgesucht und sie auch nicht selbst verschuldet hat. Und alles, was diesen Sätzen widerspricht, finden wir bei Mangold. Einfach mal ein Staat, erarbeitet von Generationen, beruht auf auch kritikwürdigen Sachen, will er einfach hinter sich lassen, einfach alles abräumen.
Wettbewerb, jetzt denken wir an das Individuum, das gilt es zu schützen.
Weil er fasziniert ist von einer kleinen technischen Errungenschaft, die zugegebenermaßen clever, klug und ja, das war es dann aber auch. Also gewinnbringend ist sie noch niemals eingesetzt worden. Außer in monetärer Hinsicht, aber das ist auch wirklich das einzige. Und wie man aus nichts und dann noch von sich selbst sagen, ich komme ja aus der Welt der schönen Künstler, von Technik keine Ahnung, so eine Ideologie daraus ableiern kann, wie Mangold ist wirklich ein Verbrechen am Denkapparat, den jeder in seinem Kopf hat. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Wer denkt, war das jetzt schon der Höhepunkt des Alens? Nein, wir werden uns noch ordentlich steigern. Wir haben wirklich alles hier vorbereitet. Außerdem sprechen wir über das Buch Fahnenflucht in die Freiheit von Thomas Wagner, der darüber nachdenkt, wie man jenseits von Staaten eigentlich zum Beispiel Demokratie organisieren kann. Dann habe ich ein grandioses Buch gelesen mit Stories von Joy Williams. Die Autorin ist fast 80 Jahre alt, ist US-Amerikanerin, aber hier kennt man sie gar nicht. Sie ist jetzt erst einmal so richtig in Deutschland entdeckt worden. Der erste Band liegt vor und ich bin hingerissen von diesen abgründigen, sehr, sehr brillant geschriebenen Stories. Und dann werden wir uns mit ChatGPT beschäftigen, nämlich wie bringt man eigentlich Computern das Sprechen bei? Da gibt es einen sehr, sehr guten, langen Artikel zu, wo das erklärt wird und warum das mit Bildern z.B. viel leichter ist mit Bilderkennung. Dann ist der deutsche Film bekanntlich in der Dauerkrise. Da werden wir uns mal anhören, was Dominik Graf dazu sagt. Und wir schauen noch auf die Aufrüstung, denn das ist jetzt auch an der Börse ein großes Thema.
Sehr gut. Also Köktürk über den Unsozialstaat. Dann werden wir lesen, warum die Finnen so glücklich sind. Beziehungsweise die Finnen sind jetzt laut so einem UN-Development, Sustainable, irgendwas mal wieder zum sechsten Mal in Folge zum glücklichsten Volk der Welt erkoren. Und die New York Times ist mal hin und hat nachgefragt und stellt sich heraus, schwierig dem finnischen Glück was abzugewinnen oder es vielleicht sogar auf sich übertragbar zu halten. Und zwei Themen zum Essen. Zum einen dieser Spiegelaufmacher aus dem Februar noch, aber der muss hier mal gelesen werden, denn das Essen und die Generation werden hier mal auf interessante Weise zusammengebracht. Und das Ganze flankiert durch einen zweiten Text in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung über die neue Nahrungsmittelproduktion. Ich bin wirklich immer noch erstaunt darüber, was so möglich ist. Horizontales Farming. Also im Katar ist es warm und man hat viele Touristen, die müssen versorgt werden. Wo kriegt man das Essen her? Und dort steht die größte Indoor-Feldlandschaft der Welt. Und funktioniert nach ganz neuen Prinzipien. Man erntet schon gar keine fertigen Früchte mehr, sondern nur noch ihre einzelnen Bestandteile und so. Da gab es einen Besuch vor Ort. Das ist ganz interessant.
Das ist alles im Salon zu erleben. Der Salon ist bekanntlich buchbar über Apple und Patreon. Wir empfehlen aber Steady, denn dort bekommt man das gesamte Paket mit allem, was man braucht, Kapitelmarken. Und dort sind auch alle Salons von Anfang an präsent bei Patreon und Apple. Das hat erst vor einem Jahr begonnen. Aber dennoch kann natürlich sein, dass man es bequemer mögen, ohnehin schon bei Apple sind und dann ist auch darüber buchbar. Und weil ja Ostern ist, noch mal der Hinweis, wer jetzt noch dringend ein Ostergeschenk benötigt und sagt, ich schenke jetzt mal den Salon, ich habe da ein Bitcoin-Pro, der muss mal aufgeklärt werden, was auch immer, dann ist das auch möglich über Steady. Die bieten das Paket dann auch als Geschenk an. Das kann man da einfach sich herbeiklicken. Dann würde ich sagen, dann sehen wir uns im Salon.